happy two-week anniversary what is it  with you and like bags of people  harley she's head of the suicide squad  you never returned my email why are you  stirring up drama right now this is not  drama okay what's she gonna do she's  wearing a pencil skirt  harley and ivy are back  let the bang kill tour begin  bff gfx right  [Music]  it's so fun and then raunchy and then a  little scary  oh that's terrifying  oh my god  shall i continue it's not worth it  let the grand orgy begins  please james garner taught me  there it is  you are gonna creep when you hear this  plan it would make lex luthor [ __ ] his  pants that man does not [ __ ] his pants  for anything  you